[Music]
[Applause]
I'm so excited to be here to talk to you
about food and there's so much to cover
so I'm just gonna go right into it so I
love this meme when I was a pup I had
one toy and it was a stick and I think
about this it's like this is like
writing CSS 15 years ago where we didn't
have the technology that we have today
we have Grid we have custom properties
there's so much at our hands and it
makes writing styles for the web such a
joy CSS still has its downfalls its chat
right let's talk about form styling why
why can't we styled forms in 29th prop
downs if you're familiar with w3schools
it's like a CSS HTML and JavaScript sort
of Education site that shows you the
basic ways to write web for the code and
so I saw this custom drop-down on their
end oh cool and so the steps that I'm
looking for is like okay we had HTML
that sounds about right
for adding CSS that's fine dude there's
like some your studio elements there and
then I scroll down and it's the scripts
and I'm like oh I still today and it's
so frustrating because I like to
separate my logic and my styling can't
do it from the web we can make idioms on
the wet ingredients our cool dynamic you
can create a comma separated list of
values this is all live a page you can
adjust these things you can remove ends
you can layer them so they become this
really great tool when you're creating
filters filter effects on images or just
backgrounds page I love you
on the web you can trick on ingredients
yet conic vidiians start at the top
point makeover round a center back to
that top point so if we wanted to create
a continue if we want to create a
continuous conic gradient we would just
add the same color for the first value
in the last value and we have a
continuation there but when we look at
can I use we can see that kind of
gradients are not very well supported
and so we can't really use those on the
web
animated gradients are also something
that doesn't currently exist in CSS
right here I have an example where I
have a div and when I hover it I'm
converting from red to blue so that's
what I'm trying to do inside this linear
gradient I'm setting it to go to right
and going from red to blue and then
transferring to deep pink and as you can
see when I hover on this gradient this
div it's not able to transition that
value and we'll get into a little bit
later so not able to do on the web
custom borders are something that you
can kind of do on the web we have a
border image property which is pretty
cool but it's still pretty limited
because if you wanted to do something
like a corner shape which would mask
your image as well as apply a border
shape on that element this is not
something that you can do and this is
from a 2013 a spec from leo who tried to
push this forward and it never really
got into browsers sad but there's
Houdini Houdini is super-exciting who
here has heard of Houdini awesome who
here has used Houdini there's like five
people and those people who like wrote
this back right here in the front so I
get to present to them Thank You Houdini
if you haven't heard of Houdini it's
really really cool it's basically a
low-level API for CSS and more
accurately it's a series of api's that
give developers access the CSS object
model and allow us to tell the browser
how we want it to read our CSS code so
this is kind of what happens now if you
want to style something on the web that
doesn't currently exist as a CSS
property and value pairs something that
you can write in CSS you have to write a
JavaScript polyfill for it so your
browser goes through this parser step it
reads the Dom it reason CSS object model
goes through cascade layout paint
composite and then you have to do that
all over again with the JavaScript
polyfill because you're reapplying style
to the page after it's already loaded
ones but with Houdini we can apply those
styles
correctly to the CSS so we have so much
power as developers now because we can
tell the browser at that CSS step what
it should be doing when it's reading our
code exciting so while it takes a while
for specs to sort of get implemented in
browsers that's sort of like this big
dog here taking its time that's a good
thing we don't want the browser's just
implement anything but if you wanted a
feature that doesn't currently exist you
can be like this little pup err zoom and
by creating your own tech creating your
own CSS polyfills writing javascript to
do it and it exists in the browser it's
pretty cool so the best resource for
this right now is is Houdini ready yet
calm and in here we list all of the
browsers that have agreed to implement
this spec as well as w3 expect to
actually go and read and the current
state of the basically the can I use for
Houdini and as you can see it's very
experimental it's very much a work in
progress the most supported AP is are
the paint API and the type object model
and so because we have them at a time
that's we're gonna focus on here today
so let's start with a typed object model
so the typed object model allows for us
to have more semantic CSS parsing so
what does that mean right now when the
browser reads CSS it has to go through
this whole string based regex parsing
and that's slow so it's looking at this
it's looking for an ID or a property or
a class looking for a specific keyword
and that's string which is like the dot
here and then the string from that dot
until that open curly brace then it's
looking for a property value a colon a
value a unit and looking to the
semicolon it has to make sure all those
are accurate values and they work
properly so this can get really messy
really fast and it's just so much slower
than having some structured data so the
typed object model provides that
structured data for CSS and that makes
it a lot faster to parse so we can do
get computed style map get a value like
height and we return a CSS unit value
which is this object that returns a
value in a unit so
this is a lot more semantic and so
therefore it makes it faster to read
through that CSS and so here I'm doing
is I just have a box it has width and
height and we can explore we can get
properties from computed style map and
we can also set properties so you could
do attribute style nav set property and
then I could specify CSS number giving
it a type and then it's going to update
that and when we console that again we
see that we're getting our height in our
passing and if you do look at this in
dev tools you will get the CSS unit
value object where you have that unit
and value separated out so that leads me
to the properties and values API which I
think is one of the most exciting things
to happen to the web in a while but I'm
biased I love CSS have has attorney had
used custom properties right now yeah
okay cool that's like probably thirty
percent of you custom properties are
really great because their actual
dynamic CSS variables that we have in
the browser so unlike sass where you
have a static variable that you're using
it's gonna pour it out to just some
value here you can actually update these
and JavaScript you can separate your
logic and your styling again because you
can keep the style part in CSS and do
the logic to change that value inside of
your JavaScript and then pass it and
they're super super dynamic and cool so
you get a name and a value with your
basic custom properties but with the
properties and values API you get so
much more than that you can specify a
name for it a syntax for it an initial
value definition and if it isn't going
to inherit from its parent so let's take
a look at that example again with the
gradient so here we have our box and I
have a color so that's custom property
and I'm transitioning from that color
I'm specifying the transitions going to
be one second long and on hover it's
going to turn blue so again still not
getting an interaction here it should
take one second to transition that color
but we can register a property called
color stop we can call this whatever we
want so here I have color stop the
syntax is color I'm specifying that
syntax I'm not gonna have an inherit and
the initial value will be transparent so
now if I update all of this if I update
this to color stop if I update this
value here also to color stop and
update the transition to color stop if I
create the hover to match all of those
and run this it's going to slowly fade
into the blue I love visual demos again
it's just like wow I typed one thing
differently I've registered property
there's so much meaning behind that
property now it's not just a string
value so there's actual meaning for the
browser to understand interpolation
between these two color values the other
cool thing about custom properties is
that you can set initial values and so
you get set fallback value so here I
have two registered properties I have
color primary and color secondary and if
you look at the CSS what we're doing is
we're transitioning from color primary
to color secondary on hover so we're
getting that animation we're getting
that one second transition but if you
notice I'm not actually specifying that
custom property that variable inside of
the CSS here I don't have to do that
because I've registered it in the CSS
not register property so I can update
color primary I can do color primary red
and then if I run this it'll update to
red there's no problem there we can
always update it but if I don't have a
value here if I have a falsie value like
23 it'll always fall back to that blue
violet now let me show you what happens
when I don't register a custom property
if I have 23 and I that's an invalid
value therefore color in the background
and I run this it's going to fall back
to transparent because it doesn't know
how to read that value and the best
thing about CSS is that when there is a
false line it doesn't crash your program
it just ignores that line so you can
continue living your life but it's
something that we can now look forward
to with this sort of --arch handling and
type checking for a CSS and so this is
kind of like having type CSS variables
and I think that's great for CSS systems
design systems making sure that
everything is super cohesive and aligned
when you're building for the web with
CSS with your team so now I want to talk
about the paint worklets
and the paintwork lid if you've heard of
service workers or web workers kind of
works the same in that it's a layer
between your network and your website so
service workers allow for blank
we rendering your assets push
notifications and that's because they
live in this in between when you open
that website you register that worklet
onto your website and then you have them
formation from that worklet whether they
be a cash or whatever else so you can
always access that even if your network
is offline so if we are registering our
work list if we're working with the
paint worklet or the animation worklet
or the layout worklet what we do is in
our JavaScript we will register that
worklet type so if we're using paint as
register paints we give it a name I'm
using a class here you can just put it
all in there and HTML we do CSS stop
paint rechlicz add module to add it to
the page and then you call what you're
naming register paint and then CSS you
would specify that work with my name so
I called it fun in this example and in
the CSS I will be able to background
paint fun so is this JavaScript and CSS
yes so let's take a look at this little
example that I made it's just some text
and what I'm doing is I wrote this
little rainbow ties worklet where I'm
just going from the top left to bottom
right and adjusting the size with these
pixel values and then in the HTML I'm
adding the worklet to CSS CSS that paint
works on add module and in the style the
way that I get to use it is just by
setting a background image you can set a
border image you can use this in any way
you want and it's just one line of code
to get all of those effects in CSS
separate those concerns here's our kind
of gradient again so you can write
polyfills like right now there is a
polyfill you can pull that into here
this polyfill is by way of room we're
writing out this worklet to allow for
connect gradients and also you can send
in contacts geometry properties and
arguments so sending in those arguments
allows us to in the CSS type in here red
and then we can run this and in the
browser we get sort of what we saw
before where that gradient is now a full
circle which is pretty cool the future
syntax is going to allow for us to use
these in variables where we can do
background connect gradient and then
inside of that have this syntax but
right now that doesn't work again this
is very experimental don't at me this is
a lot like extending the web and that
really cool you're extending the web
with CSS so I work on material I work on
material design now and one of the
things that we do is provide a platform
for developers to create their own
customized themes and so that includes
color typography it also includes shape
and this example is one of the samples
called shrine where we have this angular
shape so these are the two things that
we have as shape sort of specs and so
rounded corner is one and you can
definitely do that on the web but a cut
corner is not something that we can do
on the web yet and like I showed earlier
that corner shape spec never really got
put into the browser but we can sort of
work around this you can create a CSS
Houdini paint worklet and this is one
that I made to just specify the
different corner radiuses paint style
could be outline or filled and you can
just start to really play and get a
really good feel for this you can use
masking as well as background I know the
examples I was showing was using
background but when you're using WebKit
mask image you specify what you're
putting as your mask on top of any
element so that's kind of weak yet for
the output and then I combine these
techniques to recreate these material
buttons but with all of the notches here
so these are the original buttons and a
big challenge here was containing that
effect when you hovered that ripple
effect and so I used a mixture of
background and mask when I was creating
this notch corners worklet and applying
it in the CSS to these outlined buttons
and filled buttons so you could take
existing infrastructure and just
progressively enhance it because you can
use that supports if you're using
background you don't even need to use
that supports will just fall back to the
previous lines in CSS and this is the
way that we can integrate it into our
UIs now so let's make some magic I'm
going to do a live demo here and wish me
luck warnings this is experimental so
have experimental web platform features
enabled the paint API is enabled in
Chrome stable but sometimes things
happen also you must be using HTTP or a
local host and that's because this
worklet does live outside of your
Paige you've registered it and it's just
for security and I hope this works so
[Laughter]
let's start with a canvas I have a
canvas here that I've set up and so it's
just giving it a width and height I'm
gonna zoom in here so you could see us a
little better and so inside of my
JavaScript what I'm doing is I just have
a random function I'm setting up the
canvas I'm giving some parameters for a
sparkle height width weight and position
it's going to randomize the height width
and weight of that it's going to analyze
the position of that we're going to set
the stroke color we're going to then
paint this so that's why every time i
refresh I'm going to get a random
sparkle on this page but we don't want
one sparkle right we want probably
multiple sparkles so let's set 30
sparkles we are creating a loop here so
it could loop through and apply those
sparkles so now once this reloads we
have all the sparkles we have 30 that's
a good start
I feel like this color yellow is a bit
too similar here so we can use HSL
values to get a really saturated value
some doing a random between 90 and 100
hue is going to be around the yellow /
orange range and light is going to be
the thing that changes the most so then
I can just get rid of our color and so
we have this canvas but I want to
convert that now into a paint worklet
right so let's get rid of all this and
let's use something that we're all
familiar with and that is the X let's
hope this works this is the code pen for
the X so did you know that this X is
running in a code pen and you can go and
change it the main thing here is that
all the tiles sort of keep their
position so I'll show you what that
looks like here and if i zoom out all
the way you can see that this is the
layout for the X up there and we're
going to try to make some Houdini magic
work in that X so what we need to do now
since we got rid of the canvas in the
HTML is get rid of the canvas in the
JavaScript since we're not using this
stuff anymore and we have to start
writing a worklet so let's do that
let's
do a little type check so we can say if
typeof register paint is not equal to
undefined then we will create a class
okay class called sparkles and then
inside of that we want to use paint so
we're going to get the context and the
size of the div that we want to apply
this to and from there we want to just
put all of this inside of here so
everything that we just did we created
those sparkles we're going to place
those inside here so now I have these
beginnings of a work lip but we have to
register it so let's go right outside of
our statement where we're checking to
see if this is even supported and we'll
do a register paint and we'll do
sparkles as the name of it and we have
to call that class sparkles so what we
have to do now is make sure that we're
getting the size and height not from the
canvas but from the element so we have
to update that to size that width and
size height we have to make sure that
we're going in here and actually calling
this javascript code and so the way to
do that inside of code pen is to use
your pen ID it's a little hacking so I'm
going to write a script and now I have
to register this in HTML so I'm gonna go
down here I'm gonna do CSS dot paint
worklet the add module and then I'm
going to type that URL yes because it's
going to then link to this file in
theory so I'm just going to say that and
then inside of our tile which is every
single one of those tiles I'm going to
do a background paint sparkles and if
this all worked out we'll see some
sparkles sometimes I have to refresh for
it to work oh no what happened okay
let's go through this okay so we've
registered our worklet it has a name we
are adding it to the HTML with this
script yes it's not paint worklet dot
add module and we're applying this to
our tile with the name that we called
for the tile
well this is not working so we're just
gonna do this inside of a another little
starter and I'll just show you what it's
supposed to look like because this
worked this morning I swear so we have a
backup darn I wish that worked so much
that would have been so cool okay so you
can play with these slides you can play
with that code pen which is really
really cool what I did next was I got
these input properties so I'm pulling in
the input properties from our document
here where I'm creating a custom
property called sparkle num the way that
I'm animating it is creating a key frame
called sparkle and I'm pulling those
values in and updating those and using
that as my animation since this is not a
registered property it's not going to
interpolate between those values so you
can actually specify how slow you want
the animation to be it's not going to
interpolate those every time thing I
learned yesterday so that's sort of what
that looks like but remember what I
mentioned that this was truly JavaScript
in CSS so I am video who creates CSS
Houdini rocks created this demo where he
created a work that that just evaluates
a custom property so you can basically
in your CSS put all of this code and
then you can apply the background paint
inside of your CSS and it's super super
meta but like you're writing all your
JavaScript and CSS isn't able to apply
it so it's kind of fun I thought you
might like that but so thank you
so there are some caveats to this
approach and that is that it's semicolon
sensitive so if you like like to rate
your JavaScript without semicolons not
gonna work you have to do that because
the way that it purse is also your
variables must be that instantiation
they're not dynamic so you can't really
get those static properties and then
apply those here you just have to have
it all in one place I would love it if
that could be its own custom property
that you include inside of your elements
but you can't do that right now you just
have to make sure it's all in place if
you do that method which I don't think
is the best illusion but now I want to
talk about something extra because it
never hurts to be a little extra an
extra dot CSS is a little library that
I've been working on that allows you to
use Houdini today in your own
applications this is a CSS Houdini paint
API library from making your sites a
little more extra and you can go to
extra - CSS nullify com - check it out
so what we can do here is play with all
of these different things like the
sparkle demo you can change the number
of sparkles um you can make them bigger
by changing the width variance the
height variance you can change the
weight to make them thicker you can
create this little scalloped border
which changes the number of scallops
give it any color you want you can play
with the weight of that so you can
adjust that here why have one underlined
when you can have many underlines so we
have super underlined you can adjust the
number of underlines the spread of those
underlines the weight of those
underlines and just have a little fun
playing with that there's a cross out so
you can adjust this color too and you
can change the weight of this cross out
and then confetti because who doesn't
like confetti confetti is a fun little
thing to add to any website and here you
have control over what that looks like
so the way to use it is you can use this
right now by setting it up with one CDN
link so inside of the HTML this example
I'm going to close that results what I'm
doing is we're just including the
worklet as a file shout-out to my groups
Mueller who's my first contributor and
was working on this with me yesterday I
think ill
yeah JFK so here you can include your
script and then inside of your CSS you
can set properties if you want to
override them or you can just use
background paint extra cross out and
it'll take the default values as I
showed you before so with one line of
code one script inclusion and one line
of CSS you can have Houdini working
right now in chrome stable in the future
edge which I also test these slides on
and they worked so that was pretty cool
and so I hope to see a lot more of this
in the future I think it's a really
great way that gives developers so much
control over the styles of our websites
so you can combine all those things to
make layouts like this and as akka said
i do sing songs for every intro to my
podcast so I thought that I would end
this with a little ditty can I get some
music all right I'm not a great singer
but I'm doing this for you all now if
you source in laugh even almost native I
could say think you don't have to yell I
still don't understand
one Tommy love once help me build
patience one Tommy team now my page
looks amazing
I've learned that I've shipped but
please don't look at it if it's from
2012 cos changing tech is a habit into
that I say thank you
next thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]